quand les législateurs et les décideurs politiques, lorsque les contribuables et les citoyens,
conviendront que c'est ce que nous devons faire
et que c'est ainsi que nous devons dépenser notre argent.
Nous pourrions fournir des services sociaux de la petite enfance
aux enfants économiquement défavorisés et perturbés pour d'autres raisons,
et nous pourrions le faire gratuitement.
Et nous pourrions pousser des enfants comme Will hors de la voie sur laquelle nous sommes.
Il y a autres États que cela, mais ce n'est pas.
Nous pourrions fournir des écoles spéciales, tant au niveau du école secondaire
que du primaire,
qui visent les enfants défavorisés économiquement ou d'autres façons, et particulièrement les enfants
qui ont été exposés
au système de justice pour mineurs.
Il y a une poignée d'états qui le font ;
pas le Texas.
Il y a une autre chose que nous pouvons faire,
en fait il y a un tas d'autres choses que nous pourrions faire, il y a une autre chose que nous pourrions
faire et dont je vais parler, et elle va être la seule chose controversée
dont je parlerai aujourd'hui.
Nous pourrions intervenir
de manière beaucoup plus agressive
dans les foyers dangereusement dysfonctionnels,
et leur enlever les enfants
avant que leurs mères ne saisissent des couteaux de boucher et menacent de les tuer.
Si nous le faisons,
il nous faut un endroit où les mettre.
Même si nous faisons toutes ces choses, certains enfants vont passer à travers les mailles du filet
et ils vont se retrouver dans ce dernier chapitre avant le début de l'histoire de meurtre,
ils vont finir dans le système de justice juvénile.
Et même si cela se produit,
il n'est pas encore trop tard.
Il est encore temps de les pousser
si nous pensons à les pousser
plutôt que de nous contenter de les punir .
Il y a deux professeurs dans le nord-est, l'un à Yale et l'autre au Maryland,
ils ont mis sur pied une école
qui est attachée à une prison pour mineurs.
Et les enfants sont en prison, mais ils vont à l'école à huit heures du matin
jusqu'à quatre heures l'après-midi.
Maintenant, c'était difficile sur le plan logistique.
Ils devaient recruter des enseignants
qui voulait enseigner à l'intérieur d'une prison, ils devaient établir une séparation stricte
entre les personnes qui travaillent à l'école et les autorités de la prison,
et le plus déconcertant de tout, il leur fallait inventer un nouveau programme d'études, parce que
vous savez quoi ?
Les gens n'entrent et ne sortent pas de prison sur une base semestrielle.
Mais ils ont fait toutes ces choses.
Maintenant qu'est-ce que toutes ces choses ont en commun ?
Ce que toutes ces choses ont en commun est qu'elles coûtent de l'argent.
Certaines personnes dans la salle sont peut-être assez vieilles pour se souvenir
du gars dans le vieille publicité pour le filtre à huile.
Il disait, « Eh bien, vous pouvez me payer maintenant
ou vous pouvez me payer plus tard."
Ce que nous faisons
dans le système de la peine de mort
est que nous allons payer plus tard.
Mais le fait est
que pour chaque 15 000 dollars que nous dépensons pour intervenir
dans la vie des enfants défavorisés économiquement et autrement
dans les premiers chapitres,
nous économisons 80 000 dollars en coûts liés à la criminalité en aval.
Même si vous n'acceptez pas
que nous avons un impératif moral de le faire,
c'est simplement logique économique.
Je veux vous parler de la dernière conversation que j'ai eu avec Will.
C'était le jour où il allait être exécuté,
et nous parlions tout simplement.
Il n'y avait plus rien à faire
dans son cas.
Et nous parlions de sa vie.
Et il a d'abord parlé de son père, qu'il connaissait à peine,
qui était mort,
puis de sa maman,
qu'il ne connaissait pas,
qui est encore en vie.
Et je lui ai dit
« Je connais l'histoire.
J'ai lu les documents.
Je sais qu'elle a tenté de vous tuer. »
J'ai dit, « Mais je me suis toujours demandé
si vous vous en souveniez vraiment. »
J'ai dit, « Je ne me rappelle rien
de quand j'avais cinq ans.
Peut-être que vous vous souvenez seulement de ce que quelqu'un vous a dit. »
Et il m'a regardé et il s'est penché en avant,
et il dit: « Professeur, », il me connaissait depuis 12 ans, il m'appelait encore professeur.
Il a dit : "Professeur, je ne veux pas manquer de respect,
mais quand votre maman
ramasse un couteau de boucher qui semble plus grand que vous,
et vous court après à travers la maison en hurlant qu'elle va vous tuer,
et que vous devez vous enfermer dans la salle de bain et vous appuyer contre la porte et
hurler à l'aide jusqu'à ce que la police arrive »,
il m'a regardé et il a dit :
« C'est quelque chose que vous n'oubliez pas. »
J'espère qu'il y a une chose que vous n'oublierez pas :
Entre le moment où vous êtes arrivés ici ce matin et le moment où nous ferons la pause déjeuner,
il y aura quatre homicides
aux États-Unis.
Nous allons consacrer des ressources sociales énormes à punir les gens qui
commettent ces crimes, et c'est approprié, car nous devons punir
les gens qui font du mal.
Mais trois de ces crimes sont évitables.
Si nous agrandissons l'image
et consacrons notre attention aux premiers chapitres,
alors nous n'allons jamais écrire la première phrase
qui commence l'histoire de la peine de mort.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)